save it for the podcast
do you feel it in your bones can you let
it go into your brain that the NFL Draft
is this week I thought you were talking
about this injury and your neck from
weight lifting you've lifted weights
four times in your life and you already
hurt I want to the draft don't worry all
right here's how this is gonna go we're
gonna talk a little bit of NFL news
right we're gonna get to a interview
with Sam darn 'old which is awesome
yeah which they literally just left
right and I gotta be I gotta admit it's
really hard for me not to like that kid
I could see why every team in the NFL's
like I'm gonna bet on him and then we
are gonna do Simmons's mock draft he
just got it done I'm gonna give you two
minutes per pic and you're gonna go
through and you're gonna get it's
official this is the Sims official mock
trial yeah and by the way I'm doing this
mock draft I'm not gonna go the we are
hearing no I'm hear this or I would take
this guy but I heard they might take
that guy so I can cover myself to where
I'm right for all 32 picks no I've
watched all these guys I say I would
I've watched probably anywhere between
130 and 150 guys now and your thing is
you put your your GM head on for that
team for every team this is who you
would pick that it is yes so I'm doing
it totally through my eyes my
evaluations which I've put a lot of time
and effort into and I have a shout out
to the old Leavitt argh yeah let's do it
take a look they made this for Simms the
Simmons is top seventy quarterback
rankings it's actually 71 including the
new backup for Blake bortles Cody
Kessler did we really ever talk about
how like amazing that was where the
Jaguars like would you the quarterback
that long threatened vague bordeaux
because they traded for him I know and
we broke it live on the podcast I said
you I can't believe this now you believe
that
but Simms will be drinking out of these
cups at the office now for quite some
time
how about a nice warm glass of
shut-the-hell-up shoutout Alison Turner
yes stand and stugots and all those guys
yeah quick news before we get you really
want to talk about my shoulder I do oh
it's your shoulder
oh it's my neck yes my back right so
please tell me this cuz I'd like to hear
this dr. Kevorkian No
so a few months ago I was doing pull-ups
right and this is my problem I'm not
that strong well I said can you pull
yourself up yes okay wasn't sure so I
was doing a pull-up I know when you know
when you get tired yeah like stick your
neck up
right I heard it like that and my the
back of my neck my doing the woody smile
in this hoodie and now every now and
then if I'm putting up some weight and I
am not activating my core and getting
everything ready and I start you I'll
tweak my neck instantly just doing a
pole or a push it's at this point now
it's been everything it's been
everything yeah but so you originally
felt that actually pulling up right
doing a pull up right right right
yes you got for me I mean it could be
awful pocketed yeah no it's good it's
great pie I love this it could be a
number of things I mean it could
literally just be maybe a deficiency
with your chest muscles right something
like that that's actually affecting it
interesting but I'm going to say that it
probably just pulled a slight bit
because it was like damn I've never
pulled this big [ __ ] up here before
hold on abort mission and pull now we're
like I go and I workout and I feel it
and I'm just like I thinks after draft
we're gonna get jacked for the summer
because it Sims and left go on the road
a little bit of news Nuggets Patriots do
you put any stock into this this week is
nuts with nonsense
Patriots met Lamar Jackson two weeks ago
and are intrigued and impressed the New
England doesn't do ghost guest purple
performances at their their facility you
don't like do like a come out here so
let's trick some people and we're gonna
waste the day so we can trick number 25
in the draft to it I want the Patriots a
trifle more Jackson I'll just throw this
out there the New England Patriots have
been ahead of the curve in the NFL with
the way the games played the rules for
the last 20 years that's why the New
England Patriots people forget and when
they got Gronk and Aaron Hernandez
the tight end position was seemingly out
of fashion right and the other thing
they're bringing into fashion right now
is the full-back is back in doing if you
look at the quality offenses in football
they used the full-back like the new
entry right whether it was the year I
was there and we broke the record for
most plays run in a season because of
the Chip Kelly code words that we
implemented in the offense whether it
was they said you know what we're a
balanced football team to win the first
two Super Bowls all the rules chains
will throw at forty five times a game so
that's my number one wish for the draft
it was a Lamar Jackson Ghostly it would
be amazing I'll throw these two just
these are things I thought up I knew
they were they couldn't get in contact
with him either that's what I've been
told like they had a hard time actually
scheduling the visit there from what I
was told I don't know that a hundred
percent but the person that told me in
Lamar right and the other thing is we
talked about them being ahead of the
curve I know how much Belichick I mean
just the read option and the RP O's and
I do think he thinks the league is going
that way it was a big reason why he
almost you heard the rumors a Greg
Schiano almost going up there as a
defensive mind right because he goes
he's from college he respects Greg
Schiano he can help me out with this RPO
thing and I just wonder and also the
last thing I'll say about this come this
this particular topic he's drafted
quarterback from Bobby Petrino before
him he drafted Ryan Mallett so he my
guarantee and there's something there he
goes well it's a pro-style offense he's
been in some of this before this won't
be total I know it'd be amazing he's
just so great because draft season is
annoying for this reason nobody knows
anything and they use the draft to
confirm or deny the beliefs they've had
for the last few months and the draft
doesn't mean anything it's where the GMC
people but when you're drafted by the
Patriots
it's a Belichick seal of approval and
Lamar Jackson like I told you I was
doing an interview on Sunday they're
like you think Lamar was gonna go in the
first round I was like yes like I'm
positive yeah he's going into the first
he's going the first own in the front of
he goes to the Patriots and he's the
heir to Tom Brady right oh what a story
I know it it'd be the perfect scenario
for him and I'll even throw this in and
I'm gonna give my dad credit cuz my dad
and I had this kind
this weekend and I think he made a
really good point with this and I'm
gonna say where he actually had this
conversation with Bill Cowher so I
thought Bill Cowher is the one that
should get the credit for this but he
told me about it and I thought it made a
lot of sense going back to the Lamar
Jackson reciever conversation right and
trust me when I heard I was like what
are you about to tell me what are you
what are Phil Simms of Bill Cowher
talking about Lamar Jackson receivers
it'll be our case so this is what's
exactly that's where I was like wait you
guys are clueless whatever and but he
goes on he goes he goes you know bill
said something really smart to me he
goes if I get Lamar Jackson he goes yeah
I'm drafting him to be a quarterback
there's no doubt about that but I might
throw him out on the field as a receiver
in the first year - and my dad goes oh
yeah really why and he goes because one
you just get out in the field right
there's something to that which there
really is there's true value in to being
out on a real field in a real game with
70,000 and people trying to knock your
head off right there so there is so
getting out there on the field feeling
that environment feeling the speed of
the game and then this is the part that
really got me out sure trick plays well
that could be part of it certainly and
he certainly has a skill set to be
effective in that position but he's
gonna be in the huddle he's gonna get to
hear a Tom Brady call plays he's gonna
know you know what I'm hot off these
guys I got a Tom told me I'm hot off
these guys so now he's gonna learn some
of the things he needs to learn about
the quarterback position as well right
he's gonna know oh you know when these
two guys blitz I got to turn around and
get my eyes back to the quarterback
quick so there's things he can learn for
court I just thought it was a funny
point I'm just bringing it up out of
nowhere but I I I could see the logic
there like if he goes to a team like
that or the Chargers where the
quarterback set up well you do sneak him
on the field just to get him out there
and get used to the speed of the game a
little bit I don't know I just want the
kid to succeed he's gonna yes he's got
it the other story that caught my
attention because Aaron Rodgers is the
greatest quarterback I've ever seen is
now joining the ownership team of the
Milwaukee Bucks one of the other owners
said he's a legendary player he would be
the first athlete that's currently
active in the league that would own a
piece of a major sports franchise in an
interview he said he wanted to have
steak in the region that he's been in
for 13 years and he'd love to end his
career
the Packers we just talked last week
about how this contract wasn't getting
done and Rogers needing leverage what a
crazy notion I love this move yeah it's
just it's a Rogers man yeah Aaron
Rodgers offseason he's dating an IndyCar
driver he met Dalai Lama and he's owning
a part of an NBA team Tom Brady it is
I mean first I would like to know how
much of this you know stock and Drake or
jay-z like a decimal person I know would
but it also just for the money that
quarterbacks are making this day at age
2 to where that can even be a
conversation that's the first place my
mind went and I think he's done a
phenomenal I do believe that he wants to
be a packer for the rest of his life who
wouldn't want to be I mean playing for
the Packers is like playing for the
Yankees the Red Sox it's special as
certainly is and he's done a great job I
think endearing himself to that region
in general whether it's Wisconsin going
to Final Fours that would be in there
you know what I mean that's just your
showing you're part of the community
you're invested in the rest of the
community it's not just about him and
the Packers he's giving the love back
and I think that goes a long way with
people in the community if we don't get
a chance to sit down with Aaron Rodgers
soon I'm gonna be they still promise
them to me they they did I mean I just
put it out on you that was more like no
but I also came out before the year of
his like he's coming on this year and
then he got hurt and that kind of
wrinkled thing you're you're just a
disappointing dad that doesn't deliver
I'm used to it all right so Sam Darnell
was in studio presented by Kay Jewelers
I want to say this I'm saw a lot of
tweets that were like yeah roast them
all that stuff when guys come in here we
just want to kick it with them yeah you
want to shoot the [ __ ] have a good time
enjoy them this is not football
evaluating time when they come in this
is a time for us to know them and just
get to see their personality and have a
good time both Sims and I came away
extremely impressed and I think that you
guys will see why here is Sam darn 'old
and his mom Chris so this is a podcast
is a podcast Sims and left Co podcast he
knows I mean I know who he is I have not
listened to the
I was one of the first guys to do
podcasts all the time and it's just it
seems you would lovely talks about the
environment then he talked to me but he
said that yes what helps him is that he
does it almost every day
every day and I think I feel like
episode like 1500 or something like that
right it's nuts dude I'm 37 year old dad
okay got 11 year old daughter 7 year old
I don't have time to be tweeting as I'm
working to do it she's coming for sir
some halves and Arnold this see possibly
number one pick from USC mom will be
here later but for right now your center
stage this is where we have to start off
the most important question of your week
right here please tell me more about
dick hammer here like the grandson
perspective a when I was 2 so I don't
know him that well so I'm fascinated by
this story let me just tell this to the
listeners out there but I don't even
know if he's real amazing I learned that
they're doing the Notre Dame games on
NBC this year ok and they had someone
USC and you guys came to town they had a
little montage of things that had gone
on in your life and your grandfather
whose name is dick hammer which is an
all-time great name I mean it's pretty
awesome and then the fact that he's the
Marlboro Man and this great history I
just was like wasn't an Olympic
volleyball player and my favorite story
doesn't mine is he was captain of the LA
County Fire Department went and then
played a member of the fire department
in a show and then reportedly said I'd
rather save lives than pretend to on
television get up here come on come over
here mom the real Savior yes hello
alright so yeah tell us about this is
your death yeah oh my dad and I mean I
often think about the look on his face
just with regard to how proud he be of
him but when I was growing up he
he was a firefighter you know for LA
County I don't know my mom her my his my
I saw my mom we need Chris to belt it
out there
I just called Sam's mom my mom loved my
mom mics on either that's all right all
right so please start at the beginning
one more time about your father okay so
my dad was a firefighter right when I
was growing up and he's substitute
taught on his days off and when we were
growing up he got a job as captain of
the fire department inside Universal
Studios and so that's how he fell into
the right Screen Actors Guild and he did
a post toasties ad and then he had this
rugged look they liked when is one of
the first Los Angeles Cowboys for the
marble at right man so yeah men but he
went to uh went to USC he played
basketball there right and then he
played volleyball and at the time he
played he started playing volleyball
when he was 21 years old and played in
the 1964 Olympics after that so you're
telling me all the athletic prowess in
your family comes from yourself as a
theory that everything I've let it comes
from the moms a lot of it a lot of the
times that always but but that's
interesting so of course
maybe a little ability that's unique
this is where really started it really
started because of the PD conversation
with football players and I said I think
everybody thinks players take more peds
and they actually do I said if you look
at some of the parents of these guys I
think you'd understand why they're so
big right so we're I just I was trying
to squash that beef a little bit but
okay enough of the whole I want to hear
Sam's take on that theory yes no I don't
I don't have a take on that it's crazy I
mean the stuff that we're putting in our
bodies yes all we know is that it's
something certified we don't know we
don't know exactly what we put
in our bodies we just know that it's
good for us yes and so because you know
we have a nutritionist and all these
people around us you should be this is
what you need and so don't know the
long-term effects or anything on a rat
last week said take a protein shake eat
more food or less food go to sleep do it
again the next day work out alright so
the reason we have Darnell and is
beautiful other Chris here is because of
Kay Jewelers that big time one letter
away from it being the first name but of
course Mother's Day is coming up
celebrate Kay Jewelers let's do it
together
I got a hard-hitting question yeah Sam I
saw in high school you were listed on
rivals at six foot five now you're
listed at six foot three by my man and a
half in year five you'll be five foot
ten are you the Benjamin Button of
height of the NFL Draft I guess so I
think my dad's actually shrunk a couple
inches mine too yeah I think I'm do I
think I'm doing a shrink a little bit so
hopefully I don't but you know I think I
could still be pretty good at
quarterback if I do shrink but you know
we will be prepared if the time comes
everything my high school coach like
when I would put my real weight on
things he'd be like I'm telling
everybody you're 225 and I'm like but
I'm not so don't worry about it I'll get
there in one day all right so let's just
let's just get into a little some
football because of course we enjoyed
watching you play you're the man you got
a bright future just kind of talk about
where you're at right now and this whole
thing are you ready to be done with I
know it's been exciting but just kind of
talk about if you're gonna hug it down
yeah where's your head at I've actually
decided that I might go in for the
bro-hug the broth Goodell yeah so nice I
think that's the call no but I'm really
excited I've been very excited for a
long time for these few months
but right now I'm really just it's times
moving pretty slow right now
you know the draft is Thursday I feel
like it's gonna take forever to get
there but I'm just you know every
opportunity that comes my way whether
it's you know on this show on another
you know whatever it is Logan exactly
I'm just looking forward to it I'm
embracing everything and that's really
all I can do right but at the same time
you know there's a little nerves there
but I know that all the teams at the top
of the draft are you know I think
they're ready to win
I think the Browns are doing really good
things yeah you know the two New York
teams are doing great things that all
the other teams are bound to win soon
they just need that key piece you know
the quarterback position is yeah that's
important in all of sports in my opinion
I don't know how you guys think we're
right there with you so you know it's
just do you do you have a feel you have
a gut right now as far as you don't have
to tell us anything but do you have a
gut as well tell us just tell us if you
have a good I was gonna say you look you
look slim down is this your doing
no it's no more college life yeah I
think that when he came home talking
about nutrition I was like you know yeah
we eat a good breakfast we have great
breakfast at USC and then you go to
class and then you only have 30 minutes
to get lunch so you're gonna get
whatever you need yeah energy for
practice might be a burger might be
something like that right fries
something like that is he looking slim
down when you solve a Notre Dame
definitely without a doubt I've noticed
it right away as soon as I saw you after
the season I thought it's kind of his
specialty yeah expert at looking at
naked man I haven't seen yes but I've
seen so there's some good nicknames in
this draft I see that your high school
friends we're calling you our Lord and
Savior the amount of time he'd bring
them back and then I hear that your
parents call you flatline no no was that
from an old article no he's just like
that's he's
he is the Flatliner he's funny a lot of
my high school friends really the
seniors when I played on the varsity
team when I was a sophomore all the
seniors called me big red that turned
into Big Red Dog which then turned into
Clifford and so those were kind of the
evolution of my nicknames and so we can
call you
Clifford next year when you start to
especially if you went to the Browns the
Browns of the dog pound what so we'll
see though you know it's a that's what
they called me when I was a sophomore
cuz you know it was kind of a little bit
you know belittling I guess you could
say and then the rookie right and then
those nicknames kind of disappeared
after you know my junior senior year so
but you know stronger than everybody and
you're awesome out there like let's not
call them that anymore trying to bring
it back though I like okay all right so
my thing is this is no matter what team
you go to early on you're the guy right
like you're gonna be the face of the
franchise right away but I'm curious cuz
look usc's put a lot of number-one picks
over the years is it different you don't
I mean like if you're one or two you're
the face of the Giants or you're the
face of the Browns but is it different
if it's one like why why is it different
well I think and I've said this a few
times today I think it's it's really
interesting and me and me and Josh Allen
have talked about this no matter what
circumstance it is whether it's Pop
Warner whether it's high school whether
it's college you you know the competitor
and you wants to be number one and
everything that you know it does even
even if it means you wait a little bit
and you go to a team that's maybe more
developed you know yeah it's just
something there that's you know you're
the number one pick forever all these
guys right that's a pretty cool feeling
but at the same time I would be fine
you know well I'd be I'd have to be fine
with it you know I don't have a choice
but no it's it's something I've always
dreamed of going number one but if
that's not the case and I won't I won't
you know flip the table you know so I'll
be
but I'd be really excited to go to
whatever franchise whatever organization
wants to put that trust I mean you're
somebody's number one at least at the
very worst okay so I find this that part
of your relationship or this offseason
fascinating like Peyton Manning didn't
train with Ryan Leaf Eli didn't train
with Ben Roethlisberger Phillip Rivers
or Phillip Rivers but here you guys are
the so-called dueling it out for the
number one spot what was it like like
getting to know him at first I mean I'm
from New Jersey so at first I didn't
like man screw this Josh and I'm gonna
show him who's boss in the hell of them
so what's it been like so honestly when
I first met him I was kind of like that
yeah good yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna show
this guy right away you know I got to
know we became playful and we just
really got to know one another and we
were you know we're both pretty weird or
off-the-field we're weirdos we like to
joke around but at the same time we know
how to be you know serious and when it's
time to learn ball it's time to learn
ball when it's time to you know practice
you know whatever is drops or any type
of footwork and then you know throwing
the ball you know whether it's you know
speed work combined anything like that
so we can get serious but we have really
similar personalities I think I wanna
hear about the weirdo parts
why are you weird because I'm weird
practical joke you're weird cuz you're
sweating in a forty five-degree room
okay and you have a glisten on your
forehead that's why you're weird okay no
but yeah that's the other thing is me
and Josh lived together so that was we
had to get used to that and we didn't
messy there are they good thanks mom
yeah so your vote messy red flag
yeah red flag drop them off the board
second round pick doesn't make his bed
what why didn't Josh Allen or Sam
garland go to the Browns their mom so
they're messy so we went with rosin I
know it's all right all good so this is
another part I'm truly admire so much
about you and as a player as a
quarterback you are like your mom just
was talking about the flat liner where
did that come from
how I would like to know the
conversation you have in your brain okay
when you throw a big interception or a
fumble because it just does not seem to
faze you and you come out fire in the
next series anyways I think it's the
same thing with this draft process I
know that there's nothing I can do about
it you know I make a mistake sometimes
you'll see me you know hitting the
ground or you know I I'm not gonna throw
my helmet necessarily but I set it down
really hard right and it's just those
little moments where I kind of get
ticked off and then there's actually a
moment in highschool basketball after a
junior you know we were playing we're
playing for a league championship and if
we won we would have won it outright if
we lose we tie for the lead championship
we have to share it right and so we end
up losing that game and after I I punch
my locker and I actually break my I have
a boxer's fracture and so that was kind
of you know where I started to learn I
can't react to anything bad that happens
yeah because if I do that then only
negatives can come out of it yeah and so
that's when I started to learn okay I
probably shouldn't do that and just keep
everything inside of me yeah which
really it works to my benefit um
sometimes I feel like it can come off as
me not caring about the game me not
being as passionate but that's not the
case at all I love football of you know
everything about you know scoring a
touchdown and going celebrating my
teammates but I'm not gonna be that guy
to run around and that's just not who I
am a lot of guys wrap it and they do it
well you know I think if I ran around
and if you go well that and I think I
would just make a fool out of my I mean
I'm not good at that kind of stuff
I love the way you are man don't change
I think it's a lot of the reason I mean
you're you're being talked about where
you're talking about I think the New
York Giants and I him and I have talked
about this I think part of the reason
the New York Giants like you and are
thinking about you number two is because
you have a same demeanor as Eli which is
a lot like my father who also played
quarterback for the Giants to where it
just doesn't matter you can oh you know
one day it's gonna say you suck on the
New York Post the next day is gonna say
you're the greatest thing ever and to be
like that so don't change man mm-hmm
speaking of media Chris Ann right yeah
yep he'd better spend some of that
salary and a kiss becomes the cage or
I'm his number one fan for sure I'm a
mama's boy - I understand it good for
you that's a little early Mother's Day
gift yeah and got it for the draft as
well the girlfriend really no okay I
don't just want to make sure if anymore
that cage or money was going somewhere
else you know they've been awesome
taking me around this little media tour
I'm doing and just I mean you know it's
sometimes you're not able to express the
love that you have for your parents
because if you said exactly how you felt
sometimes it could come off a little
weird and you know that's just kind of
awkward sometimes so I think the perfect
gift is jewelry for your mom especially
yeah so I think you know I would say
something it's okay you're allowed to
cry I'm saying I'm ready I want to say
this me and Sam's I'm just gonna openly
do this in faith we've met a lot of
young quarterbacks some of them we go oh
that's weird man we don't get a lot of
eye contact are not really like kind of
in possession of who they are some
people we mean go okay you this is
pitchman central yeah this is face of
the franchise died this is the reason
why everyone leaves and they and I'm not
saying it's fake not an honest finger no
I'm not at all what I'm saying is is if
flatline and all that stuff goes
together you know what I mean the
demeanor and all of that that's a props
to you props to your husband and of
course mr. dick Hammer I'm curious
rain on the pro day my my take was that
it was on was it on purpose yeah I told
I told God
that crap love God Oh because my did you
dial up the rain when it comes to this
process we focus on these little Manute
details and we blow them up like
hand-sized it's a huge deal and all that
stuff so to do it in the rain to prove a
point I thought was it was a mat it was
a masterstroke in terms of marketing
because the narrative on you switched
immediately and I was just curious if
you felt it changed like did you did you
feel after that workout people were like
talking to you differently at all well
it was what was different about it was I
didn't throw out the combine and no one
had publicly seen me throw right for
this whole draft process and I think
just wanting to see that was something
that everyone wanted you know it was
just something I had to check off the
box obviously you know I'm a quarterback
so throwing well at my pro day and then
you know I think like a quarter of the
way through started raining which was
you know pretty ideal but it you know it
wasn't like a plan or anything I was
just curious if you would like Jordan
Palmer we're sitting there going like
look it could ring oh yeah and if it
what was that that's what discussion
yeah we definitely thought about it
right it was it wasn't about you know we
weren't like oh let's let's move it
later so that we can throw the whole
time in the reaction we're just gonna
throw it this time if it rains it rains
just happened cuz pro days may have
taken on like this life of its own
remember the Johnny Manziel with the
music and he was wearing pads and then
afterwards he sold all those jerseys
like Bridgewater bridge well yours yours
was full network coverage I mean it was
like we were watching the State of the
Union yeah it was it was fun I mean it
was just another step in this long
process and it's just you know not
throwing out the combine give something
to some people to you know something to
talk about because a few weeks and then
throwing at my pro day gives people
something to talk maybe is very simple
we're very easily manipulated and that's
why if you're intelligent enough to look
ahead and go we can control this
narrative it's easy I want you to put on
coaching Chris Simms hat yeah things
that you'd like to see Sam may be
perfect a little bit more work on what
are some things that you think that
it could really help say oh I mean be
more creative than turnovers because you
didn't know everyone's been saying you
know I turn the ball over it's like I
know that I get that right that's the
obvious one I'm not even trying to fix
it yeah of course you are I mean it's
not like you're out there and and you
know again I don't look at things like
that ever and dictate let that dictate
how I look at the player anyways I mean
I take into account that you didn't have
great pass protection you had to make a
lot of plays on your own and of course
when you do that kind of stuff it's
gonna lead to some bad plays I mean
that's just the way it is to me what is
I'm not you know the things that need to
be said mean your motion ok yeah I mean
how much did you work on that as far as
making tightening it up or making it
quicker it's actually kind of quick
already yeah no and by the way you know
I was just kind of messing around you
can mess around me don't worry it's
totally fair you know the turnover
conversation I mean but yeah I think you
know we did this thing with you know
with with Wilson football's where you
know there's like this new technology
coming out where you can see you can see
kind of how fast you actually get the
ball out of your hands from when you let
go of it right and I realized that and
also with Solon science yeah it's a show
that Dilfer and John Brenkus are doing
right and they actually they did a thing
that showed me getting the ball out
quicker than a lot of quarterbacks yeah
I saw that because I mean Marino kinda
and I'm not comparing myself to Marino
but he brought the ball down here too
sure he got it out quick right so it's
just it's just my stroke everyone has a
different stroke and if I get the ball
out quick I'm not gonna worry about it
but if it does take longer then I'm
gonna address it I'm gonna get better at
it but me and me and Jordan Palmer
decided it's not that much a minute it's
not an issue cuz I get the ball out fast
for me it's just about keeping two hands
on the ball at all times two hands on
the ball that'll limit some of the
fumbles or whenever you break the pocket
and you drop the ball like that which is
what I did too I mean a lot of
quarterbacks do alright so that was the
biggest thing you worked on throughout
the process you think what was the other
like just if we're being football
technical here that you were constantly
trying to stay on yourself about I think
for me my feet get jacked up
yeah you've got great feet quick very
athletic feet but you're just saying
they get in some bad positions at times
yeah I think you know and that also goes
along with getting my hips you know to
open yeah the way that I need them to
and then get my hips stronger but also
not being lazy in the pocket I think
that's the biggest thing for me is it's
not that I try to be lazy it's just that
when I'm going through my read I'm going
through my read and my feet are just
staying in the same spot cause I got to
bring my feet with me right with my read
and that's something that I've continued
to work on this offseason and I think
I've gotten a lot better at yeah but
then also I mean I always continue to
work on how to study how to study a team
how to study against what you know with
what pressures are guys doing on the
back so you know just all these
different things as you know and a lot
goes into it and I've been trying to
work on all of it but really focusing on
those things that I you know that really
stick out as weak points in my game I
guess yeah yeah awesome I love the part
like calming your mind like you've been
working on that oh yeah yoga meditation
good for you yeah that's great I I mean
I had a I had a psychologist I used to
go talk to like legitimately like
nothing to his knowledge it was it was
even about my marriage it was everything
but you need something there to balance
out your life or get some of the
problems out so whatever that is if it's
yoga or whatever good for you how are
you enjoying this process as we wrap up
this wonderful interview though you you
guys and it's been a blast thank you for
making it comfortable and what was it
like to see all these people talk so
highly of your son like in this part of
the process I think that okay I think
that it's not as much you guys it's like
what happened last night we were at the
Westin we're going up an escalator and
half of a high school football team was
coming down and they recognized him and
the impact that he might have on some
kids yeah
and they came back up the escalator to
see if they did take a picture and you
know it's just like you know
[Laughter]
so I think just impacting our youth yes
and the type of person he is is what I'm
mostly proud of and you know the stuff
that I seen you guys are awesome you
should be proud though because I'm so
proud number one thing is your son is a
he's a good guy and I've known that from
Jump Street even just watching media
interviews and things like that as
number one feels good you should be is
gonna be crazy next week
Sam dartle Thank You Chris you're
amazing you're beautiful happy Mother's
Day
yeah I didn't get enough love mom I love
you too alright Sam thanks brother yeah
good luck man
hey calm right there yeah okay Julie are
you gonna buy yourself some bling-bling
when you get those new money are we
gonna go watch any dumb probably gonna
get a few chains so yeah I think you
could see I came away and I said it
during the interview even like talking
to him afterwards and like hanging out
and like seeing his family like I get
why GM's look at him and go I don't
think he's gonna fail right he's just
he's quick-witted he's on his feet he's
a professional he makes the eye contact
like I made it there I'm just gonna be
honest like there was a lot more
leadership in him and Jared golf and I
guess that's gonna be our litmus test
for the rest of time but I came away
even more repressed with him than I did
Carson Wentz just as like as like a man
yeah wences like a like a little bit
more of a robot like so yes he's a
little bit more just like oh I'm Johnny
professionals just the way I'm supposed
to act I'm gonna act this way Donal just
I mean as you could hear in the
interview he's just a good dude a normal
guy had quick witty dry humor but yes
it's everything you heard hour at least
I heard about leading up to this and I
think it's why yeah I mean the person is
certainly part of what you're drafting
and I think you can feel very
comfortable with
person uh and I think the thing we
talked about you know like his mom said
flatline I think that goes over big with
the NFL I mean a lot of coaches they
love a quarterback that's like that they
know when the quarterback that ever gets
too high too low and it's one of the
things I've admired most about him in
his career - he just it never changes I
mean it's that same face almost all the
time but you think he did the dishes or
Josh Allen did the dishes that's gonna
be crazy
I live with some right I'm complaining
for the first spot yes I know and it's
I'm that was another cool part of the
interview because he admitted when it
first started I did think like you know
screw him and I'm gonna put him in his
place and whatever else but you know
that's what happens is you start when
you you get to this age and you get to
the NFL I remember rookies coming like
into the NFL when I was on Tampa and
they'd always be like you know it's not
like as crazy as competitive as I
thought I thought everybody would be
like out trying to get each other and
stab each other in the back and no it's
like I know these are token answers that
you and me make fun of yes but this
players really when you get to the NFL
you should realize wait it's about me
right if I want to get on the field I
better do better like there's no point
in me wasting my energy rooting against
the guy that I'm a you know listen that
I want the guy in front of me to be the
best quarterback ever no certainly not I
would hope he maybe slips up but it's
not I'm not gonna sit there and back Oh
Brian Griese throw interceptions throw
an interception [ __ ] up this read
whatever it may be no it's just a waste
that you start to that'll affect what
you do right and that's where I think at
the end of the day you learn as you
become that's just like a life
philosophy that I always have is you
never wish for people's downfall because
that thing comes back at you so hard yes
it's not a zero-sum game
if Josh Rosen Josh Rosen and Sam Darnell
and Josh Allen and Baker Mayfield and
Lamar Jackson could all have great
careers yeah and it doesn't impact their
career any bit longer yeah all right now
we're gonna do Sims as mock draft this
is again Sims is putting on the GM hat
for all of these teams he is taking the
player that he believes they should take
when they're at that spot yeah I'll give
you two minutes for each one just so
that we have some I won't even need two
minutes like some of these I'm just
gonna go this is a pic that's it let's
see how fast we can go okay I'm gonna go
based off nfl.com and they have a
predict the pick
where fans have tried to predict the pic
got you so the first pick is the
Cleveland Browns the fans guess what
they're picking sand Arnold 36% of the
vote right Sims who should the Browns
take at number one for me then first
pick of the draft is Josh Allen for
Joshua number one yes he is I just think
that's the guy you got to go to again
listen the other quarterbacks they all
have qualities that I like but I think
at the end of the day I look at Josh
Allen between being the MVP of the
Senior Bowl and really the MVP of that
whole week in a lot of ways the combine
the pro day the little mechanical things
that I might have been concerned about
when I watch the film
I don't worry about them anymore and the
more you watch with the film the more
you watch and realize man the completion
percentage is just a total media
fixation of crap and when you really
evaluated he makes more Wow plays than
any other quarterback in the draft other
than Lamar Jackson and to me there's
tremendous upside and I think what a lot
of people are missing out I know I miss
in my two minutes no you're doing his
floor is like there's no bust factor
this guy's not gonna be out of the NFL
this the worse this guy is going to be
is like the 20th best starting
quarterback in football that's that's it
I'm just he's not gonna fall off the
earth not the man I've seen for as smart
as I hear he is from everybody let alone
he had the highest Wonderlic score and
of all these guys but yet for me it's
it's that's the guy I'm so excited yeah
the stick to football podcast crossover
I knew that you and Miller both love
Josh yeah okay that's good it's just
gonna be a very interesting year because
a lot of people don't yeah
number two the New York Giants in terms
of predict the pick yeah the fans are
predicting say Quan Barclay 51% of the
pick Josh Rosen and then Sam darn 'old
who do you have the Giants taking it to
I have them go in say Quan Barclay
gotcha
yep if I'm the New York Giants I looked
at it like this you're the Giants you
got a quarterback that's still capable
of winning and I'm not so sure in my
evaluation that I feel comfortable at
the number two pick taking a quarterback
and saying that these the rest of these
quarterbacks at least in my evaluation
evaluation are slam-dunk NFL franchise
quarterback for the next 10 or 12 so
you're saying the Giants are trying to
win now
I think so yes the Giants are trying to
win our Gettleman and I think that's
what I would do if I'm get them in yes
because to me I don't you know I don't
fancy all these other quarterbacks like
a number one or a number two pick
totally just slam dunk oh this is
awesome this is Carson Wentz I know who
they are but yes a qualm Barkley you put
that with this team who still has a
really talented defense right and you're
the New York Giants and you have Odell
Beckham jr. Evan Engram sterling
Shepherd and say Quan Barkley good luck
cover in all three levels of the field
with that group I was gonna say Phil
Jackson tried to bring the triangle
offense to New York but say Quan Barclay
Evan Engram and Odell Beckham might be
you you could have the two most
explosive offensive players in football
on the same office 1109 yeah it's an
amazing sorry New York Jets of three
yeah predict the pick the most predicted
is sand Arnold at 61% then Bradley Chubb
and then say Quan but I think we know
they're going for a quarterback yeah
which one are you giving them at three
well this isn't my gun this is my
evaluation I will really be intrigued if
it's Rosen Mayfield an Allen are in
Darnell they're all on the board for the
Jets that I just would I want to know
who they would go I don't know who it is
I don't I don't know but I'm just I'd be
interested but for me with the Jets and
the number three pick and evaluating
their football team I'm going Josh Rosen
Josh Rosen is the guy to me first of all
I do think this personality will fit
fine here in New York I think he's the
most ready and if I look at this team
right now and I'm Todd Bowles and
everything about it too I go yeah I want
a guy that can come in here and play and
kind of take us up to that next level
into the playoff conversation not maybe
into the playoffs but in the
conversation and I think Rosen is the
right guy to do that he's been in a
similar type offense in UCLA Jed fish
runs like a West Coast offense Jeremy
Bates old my old friend from down in
Tampa it's a similar thing so he's seen
the crossover on film now Rosen's not
perfect I know that he's not gonna be
able to do all the movement stuff maybe
if Jeremy Bates was but if I'm the New
York Jets Josh Rosen he checks all the
boxes exempt or just a hair lat les
athleticism I would like yeah and maybe
the frailness but other than that EADS
he's a what I would call a dead dick
thrower so what yeah it's just a
technical phrase sounds real scientific
yeah Chris Sims is my
tref thus far he has Josh Allen going
number one say Quan going number two
Josh Rosen going number three number
four yeah back to the brown back to the
brownies the most picked ear is say qua
knees obviously not available number two
is Minka Fitzpatrick according to the
fans yes where are you going in there
both you know okay why did Cleveland
bunch of real Preppers if they wanted to
minkum Fitzpatrick you got your Braille
you're stuck with them sorry okay I just
you know number four number four Bradley
Chubb North they leave this draft with
Josh Allen Bradley Chubb yes so their
quarterback of the future and then
Bradley Chubb and miles Garin Bradley's
a hell of a draft all right hell of a
draft I mean you're already now you're
in the conversation for the best passers
rushing duo and all football behind the
Chargers behind the Jaguar ice yeah but
it's in there we're talking about it
right and I look at Bradley Chubb and
just go he's kind of a can't-miss
prospect he can do everything I mean if
you need it into the play three four
outside linebacker you're there's plenty
of film you could see him dropping back
in zone drops he's very good in space
but he's going to be a defensive end at
the end of the day I compared him the
guy I wrote down was Olivier Vernon when
I looked at the notes right so people
are right might have years where yes
twelve and thirteen sacks next year
might be just as effective but he has
eight right you know whatever it may be
but I think that's a no-brainer for the
Cleveland Browns I'd say right now it's
uh pretty by-the-book right like what
you're doing except we have no Sam
Darnell which it sounds like that's
going to happen and this is where
apparently this is where I me they're
gonna be really wrong or really right in
the future it's all about the GM's
preference yeah number five the Denver
Broncos
okay the Denver Broncos so this is to me
where it made sense I did one trade I
don't like to do trades okay but this is
the time I did the trip out to five and
you went that's I think there's a trade
just from what the Broncos need okay
as a team and need team needs all
together listen they certainly can use
offensive linemen so like Quentin Nelson
crossed my mind here there's a few spots
maybe a receiver
maybe another DB regardless exactly
where they trade them so they're gonna
go with the bills the bills they they'll
trade it to get up to twelve so you're
saying the bills move up to get up there
at five right and who are the bills
taking this is where if I'm the bills
I'm going back
Mayfield Baker Mayfield number five pick
now I've heard that they don't love
Baker Mayfield
but again Baker feat Mayfield's the
third best quarterback in the draft for
me this is you're a few G this is me if
I'm the GM yes I mean Baker Mayfield's
got very good feet he is a phenomenal
thrower the football I mean you're not
gonna see you can't see a handful of
throws the whole year where Baker
Mayfield really misses targets or loses
control of the ball the ball almost is a
perfect spiral so a lot of people think
Baker is gonna go five but to the
Broncos but you see the bills jumping up
there I do and I think the Broncos at
the end of the day I mean you just got
you're gonna I just I just don't see it
I think they're gonna be playing with
fire and having Case Keenum a Baker
Mayfield both in the same and I think
case Kingdom's a were the NFL starter
for right now I just wouldn't mess with
that I think this is a Bronco team
that's kind of close and I would let the
team here ride it out one more year or
at least Josh Allen at one Josh Rosen at
three Baker Mayfield at five Sims has
three quarterbacks going in the top five
number six according to the fans that
have voted the leader
Quinton Nelson at 81% yeah - or the
Colts do you agree with them I I
certainly thought but I do not agree
well I do not you know they're not going
quarterback so who you going with the
coat the Colts have more offensive
linemen than you think
okay injury a lot of injuries right it's
not the worst group in general you're a
very beat up last year yes and I do
think that you know they got a look at
that and go that's not like the most
desperate need on their football the
interesting to me where I look at it in
secondary that is certainly one there
was its secondary or front seven they
have to have some difference makers they
have no difference makers on their team
other than Andrew Luck and T Y Hilton I
mean you can't can you name anybody in
their secondary I mean that's what I
mean most people can't it's on today
he's not there anymore TJ Green right
Yeah right right
they got this Malik hooker in the safety
right you have to last year right but
they have no corners I'm going I'm going
with Marcus Davenport from University of
Texas San Antonio Wow yeah number six
number six listen there's not a lot of
planet people on planet earth that are
six for 264 pounds and ran four or five
okay that just you like this kids Phil I
do
like this kids film now am I gonna send
here a Landry over at romaine Edmonds
over a row Quan over a Derwin you're
going I think at six
this guy is a can't-miss prospect I'm
not sure he could necessarily be the
superstar Harold Landry can write like
Harold Landry has superstar capabilities
Kay but he's not these good all-around
football players market staff and poor
in my opinion Davenport like we just
talked about I mean almost thirty four
inch arms with that kind of size right I
just look at that for the Colts which
are gonna be running right we got to
remember the Dallas Cowboy defense now
okay they got I'm blanking on his name
if you can look up the defensive
coordinator Matt a beber FLA's ever full
of ever Phyllis yes right he is the
nudie coordinator he came from Dallas
this is the guy that I think could be
their next DeMarcus Ware ish type guy
right interesting right he's kind of
have not seen that anywhere so I'm doing
it and yeah I I think he's a phenomenal
football player and a difference maker
and really a safe pick at number six to
to where you know again the floor is
like ten year starter and a few Pro
Bowls maybe like he's not gonna be a
disaster it's fun for everyone that I
hear he goes will he play the Texas San
Antonio can't be that great yeah I know
Mac played a buffalo but you know what's
that teaching us
so that's the first shocker Marcus
Davenport going six ok now we're at
seven for the Tampa Bay Bucs yeah I
don't know where you're going here but
quit Nelson it's quittin else it has to
be yeah it is I mean I thought about
secondary here cuz they they are a team
that could use some secondary I thought
about like the minka Fitzpatrick's even
Derwin James crossed my brain but to me
at the end of the day we've been talking
about no run game in Tampa for three
years and no pass protection for the
line is by far the shoddiest yeah I
think it's the biggest positional need
and I also look at it like this we're
okay just look at them and go they might
there's there's some safeties and other
secondary players in this draft that
they could probably get the second and
even third round but there's you're
saying the corners were in Sicily right
and those safety nickel hybrid type guys
there's a ton of them you know they have
Grimes they did take Vernon Hargreaves a
few years back in a top 10 pick so I
just thought this people might have said
DN
let's remember Vinnie curry was paid
three years 27 million and they traded
for jpp I have a hard time things are
gonna do another offseason asset on a
defensive end there so that's why I go
Quentin Nelson who come on like we've
talked about I feel like if quit Nelson
went second I'd still be okay with ya
you you could be you're right you're not
gonna it's not gonna be wrong I mean
it's just not sexy I don't like taking
guards at number two because I don't
know if they can make a huge I would
argue that interior pass rush is the new
way of maybe you do all right now let's
go to eight the Chicago Bears yeah
where are you going with the Bears so we
got a lot of the secondary guys still
available yeah
you've taken away one of them excuse me
one of the pass rushers the bestowal
lines gone you go in line back or you go
and secondary here what are you thinking
okay so this my secondary thing came to
this right because I thought about that
but they just paid Kyle fuller all that
money right so and Kyle fors awesome
they rescind Prince Amukamara as well
and the number one predicted guy for
this pick is Denzel would make sense
right that's what I figured and that's
where my mind originally thought but
that one you have to do your research
what you do so ok look at that then the
next place that your mind goes to is
offensive line right right that's the
other place I look to but you've already
given away Quinton Nelson right and
you're gonna be she and do they really
need I had an offensive lineman people
are telling me that but not sue garasu
whatever I can't say his name is cross
Thank You Cody white Cody white hair
please Kyle long right there tackles I'm
blanking out on their names and hold on
I'm getting there you know yeah Bobby
Massie still okay he was there and I'm
missing our other damn tackle here all
that would of course be Charles Olano
jr. thank you so they're not desperate
for often where'd you go I went with
linebacker Vic Fangio he's trying to get
his new Patrick Willis and that's where
I go term ain Edmonds for main and
mizzen right it's a three-four defense
he was right you want a new Brian
Urlacher in town here you go huge
linebacker ultra athletic gonna be
amazing in the pass game and has the
size and traits you want for a
three-four middle linebacker that's
where it makes sense to me
listen the guy's a freakin
we know that if there's one negative as
we're talking about him out here it's
just I wish he was a hair more of a
sledgehammer as a middle linebacker but
he's 19 years old like just turned 19 so
wild it is wild but he is he's the guy
for I'm like in your middle part of the
top ten six you're going Markus
Davenport eight you're going Tremaine
Edmunds with Quinton Nelson what's it
these are studs that are getting pushed
down that's right because of the
quarterback I I think so too and yeah
and to me I just feel like guys like
Marcus Davenport always end up going
higher every year and I sit there with a
week pass rush right and I sit there
going wait why didn't I pick the guy
that's six six and runs for five to be a
top twenty pick that is so I was like
that's stupid he's a difference maker
he's gonna go to the top so alright so
that the the most selected guy for the
Niners at nine was Tremayne Edmonds
according to the fans who there was
Minka Fitzpatrick yeah so tremaine's off
the board
Davenport's off the board all the
secondary guys are still there for your
favorite coach excuse me are where are
you going at number nine at number nine
who are you given to the Niners yes this
was a tough one because there is the
whole Reuben foster situation right so
do you just slide in row Quan and then I
thought about safeties - okay all right
and like people like that right like I
cross my mind go Minka writer when are
they gonna try to find like their kam
chancellor because they run the Seattle
yeah but they have they have good safety
play so that's where I was like I don't
think so I mean the jerk whiskey tarts
the Jimmy Ward's they're still on this
football team and they're pretty
talented guys so I had a hard time
thinking that so it did it came back to
linebacker and then maybe a position
that most people don't think about but I
I do and again I don't know this from my
buddy but where are you going
I know his brain and I just think I'm
going Mike McGlinchey Notre Dame really
number nine yes you have so what about
Kyle's brain makes you think Mike's you
think that Michael Berg latency is
Lapierre I think I look at two things I
mean McGlinchey is the
tackle in the draft and he's by far the
best run blocking tackle in the draft
he's ultra athletic Kyle loves a good
run exactly right I just never know how
they fill them in here I don't I don't
know we'll figure it out because they do
have Trent Brown but and you've been
saying for a few weeks you could see
McGlinchey going top ten because of the
need and it's tackle yes it's kind of
what you just said about Davenport right
where we sit back afterwards and go of
course attack okay see Davenport at six
McGlinchey at nine Edmonds at right
McGlinchey and you also got to think
here the 49ers you have Staley right
he's coming to the end it's going to the
ass so McGlinchey is perfect there you
put him at right tackle for two years
and then oh damn you get your franchise
left tackle for the next ten years after
that yeah because I think we need to say
also that Trent Brown got rated very
highly in some scouting services but I
don't know if that sentiment is shared I
don't know either and to me I just go
from this standpoint of I've never seen
Kyle have a right tackle that looks like
that and just from one's that means well
Trent Brown is gigantic
no likes more of a mobile makes a guy he
wants a guy that's you know like 30
pounds lighter than Trent Brown who can
you know make unbelievable zone block
reach block and she has them McGlinchey
is McGlinchey was one of the guys where
I saw in person all year right and I
knew how good he was doing the Notre
Dame stuff but when I turned on the film
I went damn he's frickin better than I
gave him credit for you know what's
interesting about McGlinchey and I'll
say this about Kyle you talk about white
space we talk about the Patriots going
on tight ends and fullbacks when people
seemingly don't care the best part about
Kyle's offense is it requires an
offensive line that other teams aren't
interested in little bit yes the rest of
the NFL ones big hulking offensive
lineman and Kyle wants you to be under
sized underweight and fleet a foot and
so he's kind of scouting his own
offensive linemen that no one else is
competing I would say that to a degree
you're right and there's an advantage
that there is he's got a different set
of yeah a different man certain set of
skills
that's the block for Kyle Shanahan all
right number 10 there
Jon Gruden is hulking over Reggie
McKenzie shoulder and he's poking him
and he's prod him he's going I can get
my guy my thought is here I'm gonna
guess if I were you I'm looking at the
Vita veis right I'm looking at ro Kuan
obviously right so let's just start with
a beat of a is good thought right and I
thought that too just because they've
been getting run on for years I know but
they got like they still have Justin
Ellis in there right so he's a giant and
they just resigned him so he's there
they have guys like Darius laughs them
ed Evander who's who played well last
year I'm missing gia hogwards then I'm
also thinking corner makes sense because
right now it's Gary and Connelly and I
don't know Reggie Nelson's 35 and ain't
got it so safety is available to Obie
melon faun whoo and they got the first
round pick from West Virginia safeties
those are things that Karl Johan Josef
right yeah and then look I know Gruden's
kind of wanting his offensive guys so
man a lot of pieces I'm gonna say ro
Quan Smith because it's wrong lonesome I
I think you're exactly is that you beg
yes okay yep I think that's the way to
go here I mean no Quan in a Raiders
Jersey it is and again let's just think
paul gunter right he just came from a
vantes Burfict
this guy wrote Quan Smith is a more
explosive
vantes Burfict maybe not as loosen the
hips in the coverage like if I have one
negative about roll Quan Smith is he's
very tight in the hips like pass
coverage one on one versa back and out
of the backfield is going to be a little
bit of an issue at least in my
evaluation for him but everything else
is gonna be topped up he's a fantastic
I'm in some of the best legs and ass in
the draft alright so let me recap your
top ten number one Browns go Josh Allen
the Giants go say Quan Barclay the Jets
go Josh Rosen the Browns come back and
go Bradley Chubb and the Broncos make a
trade with the bills and they select
Baker maybe and I part of my reason
again this would be the only trade and I
really didn't want to do a trade but I
felt like this one was so obvious and
it's about the quarterback and all that
and the reason another reason I did this
trade was the Dolphins
I am worried if I'm the bills about the
Dolphins like an 11 or Mayfield right so
you need to get up in front of him so
there you
no perfect Colts at 6:00 shocking the
world with Marcus Davenport 7 the Bucs
finally getting some protection for
Jameis Winston with Quinton Nelson the
Bears come back and get sure made
Edmonds as their new Urlacher
the Niners at nine maybe a little bit of
a reach but if he's the best tackle in
the draft Michael McGlinn she's the guy
and then the Raiders at ten go row Quon
Smith
that means Sam darn 'old is not in the
top five Don the top ten yeah and he's
fallen a little bit
I'll try think what are the other
fallers Denzel Ward is a faller we
haven't said Minka Fitzpatrick Minka
Fitzpatrick but Sam darn 'old I think is
the one where if he got out of the top
ten I think a lot of people would be
shocked I mean yeah and this is Chris
Simms Jesus Chris Simms GM no punches
well he's not getting out of the top ten
so I'm going to be wrong on this and
that's okay tell me we're not trying to
guess we're trying to tell you what you
would do yes exactly right the rose' is
kicking in okay number 11 number Miami
Dolphins come up to the board
Sam darn holds their feet of AEA's there
it's a lot of secondary guys are there
and they're always seemingly drafting
secondary guys who did you have the
Dolphins taking for him you said his
name vita van yeah really and just let
go Adamic ensue and this guy this guy's
a freak it's the ugliest body gonna be
drafted in the first round but it's
unbelievable he didn't really get a
chance to talk about Vitas yeah what did
you see about this guy I mean I
literally the first thing I wrote was
ugly his body in the draft
I mean it's pitiful it's a similar legs
to Andres Pete I mean it's not it's
worse than like it's not that big and
powerful looking it's not worried about
one bad offseason I mean there's
certainly I said the only negative in
this kids game is yes like five years
from now when he has a if he has a bad
offseason does he go from 348 to 378
right that might be bad body mr. studier
of bodies if it means lack of Vike like
strong looking legs right no hamstring
no quad definition he hadn't really know
ass and then he had like a huge belly
and tire around him and how are you
because when he just throws everybody
that tries to block him off of him and
like shoulders people and they fall down
and he makes people miss with his speed
and his quickness and he's disruptive
it's one of the most unbelievable things
to watch in this trap better body him or
Danny Shelton I think Danny Sheldon's
body is a hair better better prospect of
a try to via oh that that quickly yeah
yeah via is like he can be the mosh pit
guy that Sheldon is like to make things
a mess but via can truly be disruptive
like shoot the gap and he can get
through and like we always talked about
the stat for [ __ ] the playoff yeah he
can be that guy a lot it's it's
impressive watch man and he got a thing
to he fits with what they want to do
down there that defensive coaching staff
is a lot of Cincinnati ties Cincinnati
had dome atop Petco all those years you
know this guy could be that where he's
your shade nose tackle and you're
sometimes three technique man so uh so
darn old still aboard I know he doesn't
listen to our podcast sorry Sam
sorry sorry mom and dad yeah no just
kidding
but not really Buffalo Bills have traded
the twelfth in yours to the Denver
Broncos yeah that's the first pick for
the Broncos they can get same darn
little 12 they could but they're not
where are you gonna go I'm gonna give
them Denzel word so they're getting the
quarterback that you said last week they
really liked it five yes they get him a
12 right and he's the first corner off
the ball he's the first corner off the
body not my favorite corner so I know
this so I'm again I'm trying to be the
GM and I think to me when I just look at
it and I was like you know let me be
serious here he's maybe the safest
corner okay that's where I went
you've always said he's always in the
area right he's just not always making a
play exactly if you're always in the
area
that's an amazing because it's an
amazing skill set right so there's a lot
to like there for a team that's kind of
really like in win mode now where I
thought like okay yeah I don't like this
kid as much as maybe Mike Hughes or
junior er Alexander but they're not
maybe as professional and as polished as
he is either and you saw I do see that
in Roby and him will have the Ohio State
connection and I think he has more of a
future in the nickel combination at some
point where he is
to be their future Chris Harris jr.
which I think they value greatly out
there so to me that's where it made
sense and it's the Broncos the Broncos I
still think are a team and if I'm John
Elway I'm going we can be in the mix of
things again here this year I know we
weren't in the playoffs last year but if
case water might play was so bright if
Case Keenum just plays a little above
average I do think they're a team that's
gonna be in the mix I think if I'm gonna
rate the most frustrated NFL players in
the league last year would be Demaryius
Thomas and Emmanuel Sanders
I thought about receiver and just just
watching those guys and not even able to
get the ball to them you're so
frustrating 13 is Washington yeah and
you could go in so many ways here don't
you frost my thought process here at
first was like okay do we want to go
defensive interior defensive line right
that's where I kind of went right off
the bat the most predicted player is
Vida Vegas
so apparently fans were thinking the
same thing right so I did think about
that that was certainly part of it but I
still think my evaluation from the end
of the season is still the number one
concern to me the Washington Redskins
are in need of talented secondary player
they have Josh Norman okay and they
really don't have anything else I mean
nothing proven I love Fabien Moreau who
they drafted in the third round that he
was a first round talent that torres
pectoral right right in the process so
he didn't really get to play and then of
course they traded their other corner
this year to the Kansas City Chiefs Kyle
fuller yes is that cotton Kendall right
so are you going corner or safety I'm
going the jackknife of all secondaries
and that's Minka Fitzpatrick Minka Fitz
I don't know if I can handle them in
Washington game so like that you know I
mean this is a team that needs somebody
that can help their secondary I see what
this guy is way better than the super
Cravens and a way more explosive
athletic the knock on on this kid right
here is we didn't get to see him just be
great at one position no you got to see
him be great at two positions and really
good at a third and to me he's without a
doubt he is going to be in the
conversation if you play him at free
safety at the very worst he's gonna be
one of the three or four best free
safeties in the sport from day one and
Mannis
can use him yes perfectly he's gonna be
he's great down in the nickel in the
nickel extra guy in the box he's gonna
be able to cover slot receivers tight
ends but they need a surefire we need
some depth and all-around play in our
secondary and he is like made for it 11
Miami Dolphins went in Vita via number
12 was the Denver Broncos when Denzel
Ward 13 Washington they go make a
fitzpatrick and I just want you to know
what you're creating right in the green
room right now there is a camera on
Chris and sand Arnold and they are
sitting there they're going what is
happening your life no yes no that's not
right now are you kidding me yes but
there's part of me that it's funny to
talk about this with the Green Bay
Packers on the clock at 14 what if
during this contract in case negotiation
with Aaron Rodgers they do an Aaron
Rodgers to Brett Favre tear and Rodgers
with Sam Darnell is that what you
predicted absolutely not okay who are
you going with the Green Bay Packers at
14 I am going by the way the fan
selection was Mike Hughes with 52% of
the pick at 14 are you serious yeah they
picked him yeah I'm actually really
surprised kind of higher on Mike Hughes
than most people I definitely did think
I was higher on Mike Hughes than most
people but I have them pick him Mike you
you and the fans you're a man of the
people I am a man and I love Mike Hughes
I mean he was really my favorite corner
in the dress I was gonna say I think you
were gonna put him on the Bronco yeah I
just didn't because of what I told you I
just felt like they needed a guy where
they could depend on right now right
away and that's why I went with Denzel
Ward but Mike Hughes if that went
flipped around whatever way I really
like Mike Hughes I think he is this is
the way I thought about it I thought
okay looked at their roster I understand
like I don't think offensive line I
thought maybe receiver they could go a
receiver defensive line thought about it
a little bit but they've got a lot of
they got more defensive linemen up there
than you think
yeah and I thought man it's Mike Pettine
and Mike Pettine when he was with the
Jets man he had Darrelle Revis so he
could have won
ina island and he could do a bunch of
creative stuff guy this is the best I
think usually really I think he's the
best shut down man-to-man corner in the
draft I do worry he'd just get in your
face I mean a great pick for them it
would be and I don't think they really
have a corner like that I know they got
the kid King last year right Kevin King
you know he's a tall or longer type guy
I don't think you're gonna be able to
live with him and Island all game long
they needed this part of their team and
they're in Green Bay and last time I
checked the NFC North Scott pretty good
quarterbacks now it's called sure risky
Kirk Cousins to Matt Stafford and you
need some people to cover some people I
forgot about Kirk oh yeah worry about
that alright so next up is the Arizona
Cardinals Arizona in Chris Sims as mock
draft is sitting there with Sam darn old
Southern Cal so close to Arizona oh man
Lamar Jackson who Bruce Arians is coming
out whenever anyone gives them a
microphone and saying they should draft
Lamar Jackson tipped emote David Johnson
the vote online is Calvin Ridley
I guess people saw John Brown's Aaron
Brown depart they said they need a wide
receiver and Larry Fitzgerald is getting
old yes
what are you going with for the
Cardinals at 15 that is a I'm pulling up
their roster sorry but what is your pick
my pick is team Lamar Jackson Wow Lamar
Jackson's mine
my number four quarterback on my board
right as you said it's funny I was
telling people this week that I want my
bold prediction to be that Lamar Jackson
will not be the fifth quarterback taken
he'll be the fourth and a quarterback
will fall underneath right I did not
think in the dress will be same d'Arnaud
but in your mock and my mock some I've
come true so Lamar to Arizona I do that
war room must be going I mean listen the
receiver thing certainly possibility
thought about that yes you know thought
about d-line a little bit it was kind of
all over even like thought oh okay maybe
could they use another corner in the mix
there but then I thought no this is a
guy that came from Carolina they don't
value like man-to-man
corners like that I don't think that's
it so it's a more zone base yeah first
so for me what it came down to more than
anything is first of all it's the Lamar
Jackson I think is fantastic I mean he's
got the highest ceiling in the draft
it's an Arizona Cardinals team that's
it's a small city it's a small you know
what am I trying to say a mark Media
Markt Lamar Jackson lost exactly right
would be just the absolute guy for that
type of city for the team the
organization the fans all to go look at
this guy this bright shiny object we got
on our football team and it's just gonna
give them a credible buzz and I think
he's got an incredibly high ceiling and
it's the perfect situation because they
got quarterbacks there but they don't
need him in there right what right now
and you know the last team that drafted
a quarterback that had Sam Bradford
slotted his starter Carson Wentz the
fluffy Eagles why would they draft him
they just paid Sam Bradford 20 million
dollars yeah because he got to camp and
they went oh crap Carson Wentz's Carson
yes yeah see you at Lamar I'm going
tomorrow I mean the receiver thing
listen I understand that that's the one
where we could talk about it right you
know you don't you're not high on those
guys I'm not necessarily high on them
they have good tight ends they have
David Johnson coming back and the
receiving cores not horrible and there
is a lot of receivers to pick from in
the second and third round so that has
to go into these decisions all right 16
is the Baltimore Ravens Sam Darnell just
leaned in and said Baltimore randomly
called him recently and said just want
to make sure your numbers right that was
that was actually that actually happen
are they going Sam Donald they are not
Wow all right so uh Mike McGlinchey was
number one for the fans
Connor Williams is down here at the
third pick are they going tackle who are
you picking for the Ravens I'm not going
offensive line for the Baltimore Ravens
the Baltimore Ravens offensive line is
fine Ronnie Stanley in all those boys
Ronnie Stanley Rickey Wagner
I mean Emmanuel Jermaine Elliman you're
Alex Lewis Marshall yonder I mean this
is one of the better offensive lines in
football when it's healthy so I just
don't forget that these offensive lines
burger yeah they were hurt last I saw
Peter King and his article was talking
about the Chargers offensive line was
beat up and I could
I'm going out I was like you're out of
your mind no I don't beat up and they're
all coming back right all right so where
are you going with to me it was Raven I
thought about wide receiver right
I thought about tight end who just got
Willy Sneed right they just got will
this need I thought about side end max
Willy and I just said you know what no
they need a difference maker on the
front seven they need a new terrell
suggs and that's where I'm going Harold
Landry Harold Landry yeah he is the guy
that I look at that first of all could
be the the next terrell suggs I mean he
really could be but phenomenal football
player really the most natural pass
rusher in the draft coming off the edge
great been great get off I liked all
those things about him and he's just a
badass and he seems like a Baltimore guy
I think that fits the Ravens are that
team that when you look at their roster
you go how the hell did they not do more
than yes here next year I mean the fact
that they're wide receiving corps is
gonna be Willie Snead Michael Crabtree
and John Brown they got brashaad Power
Man stashed away somewhere right there
oh line is deep they need another
running back I think to balance out Alex
Colin and Jeff aureus Allen yes guys but
their defense Brandon Carr Jimmy Smith
Marlon Humphrey Tony Jefferson Eric
Weddle at sea I mean I couldn't go say I
wasn't gonna go corner on corner last
year and they just they're really good
at picking like Carl Davis in the third
Chris Worley in the third grant urban in
the fourth right there Brandon calf you
see at the third things that great at
drafting there goes those guys later on
by Terrell Suggs first Mosley first they
like that position you know what I mean
that just to me that makes too much
sense and and I'll see you this this is
inside info right I told this is like I
just remember this conversation I had
with John Harbaugh last year
and he just said yeah we need to get a
little younger on the edge of our
defense gotta get a little more oh yeah
and I just stuck with me when it came up
to this pick I was like man I love
Harold Landry for the Baltimore Ravens
and I thought about what he said to me
and I like yeah I think it's time to do
it and Chris Sims has a mind like a bear
trap all right now we are down at the
Chargers at 1700 Sam Donna's comin to
town
that's it he's coming to town San Diego
Sam no Arnold's and if you're trying to
take over the fanfare of Los Angeles and
first of all this is where I think
people are missing on Sam Donald okay by
the way so Arnold told me that the
Chargers asked for his phone number good
they should they should this is where I
think people miss out Sam Donald again
I've been saying this the whole time
he's a top 20 pick definitely he's not a
slam-dunk number 1 or number 2 517 - so
yeah I just not a slam dunk number 1 or
number 2 in my eyes that's all I would
say and I think where people miss out
too is you know these are the things
that I mean he's still raw that's where
it like that doesn't say number one or
number two pick - me either
[ __ ] I was 18 my bed okay either way you
were close enough but you know again the
Sam Darnell he certainly has the skill
set where he can be extremely successful
but I'll just say this he's of course
very young from everybody I've talked to
in the football world they say he is the
least he is the farthest behind on
football knowledge right
oh right of the fight yeah he's the
farthest behind so he's the most raw
from that standpoint he we talked about
his feet being a little raw his
decision-making being a hair raw the
turnovers all those things added into it
that's why I just go I don't understand
the number one he's definite type 20
like I said I'll just which is amazing
right and he can be a superstar and I
might be wrong he might be the number
one guy maybe I'm wrong you just said
right now don't see the value of taking
him in the top five I don't I don't
understand that yes I do not I do not to
me he is perfect for this situation go
behind Phillip Rivers learn the offense
a little right some of those mechanical
things you have and they're gonna
unleash him and Southern Cal is gonna
back him and it's gonna be the perfect
move two or three years from now now is
the time to bring him back in Sam dard
old and the family get in here they're
gonna bring their laser point guns in
here what's funny is I was talking to
someone there and they said the Chargers
can make a run at a Super Bowl why would
they take a quarterback now right I said
because you're being short-sighted
you're looking at youth
they need a piece right now yeah I'm
telling you that they can make that run
without a what you need to realize is
when they make the switch to a rookie
quarterback you get a five-year window
if he's a first-round pick right that
you get to spend your money everywhere
else yeah so imagine the Chargers right
now with not all that money going to
Philip Rivers you could get more running
back some wide receivers and defensive
linemen you do it for the window and
Philip is nearing the end yes he is
right he's still a baller right he's
still hilarious he's still gonna curse
people out in his own weird words yeah
but a man saved Arnold the 7 so here
yeah Sam Darla that's 17 to listen the
Chargers they certainly could use maybe
a D tackle I thought about there maybe a
free safety certainly but Sam darling
was on the board that's where I thought
just big people yes just I don't know
again I'm just telling you this is what
I would do and this is how it shucks out
and I truly I mean I did this for two
days it's oh he's been just I've been
stru Lee sitting there going like man
okay I'm the GM adventured we're in the
green room with you earlier and you
notice but you were sitting there and
you're like rub on your eye and you're
like holding your head and Federer
cleans it and goes he's like really
stressed right now I was like it's a
stressful time and I don't I was well
that you guys are catching because I was
thinking about not putting that trade in
this draft right cuz it was kind of
bothering me a little bit cuz I don't
want to be that guy but this one was so
obvious I just thought okay let me do it
but yeah so whatever all right so the
whatever the Seahawks are standing pad
at 18 yeah where are they going
the Seahawks offensive line I thought
about offensive line there's a few more
players on their roster at the position
than you think right no man yeah one
who'd you pick
well let me tell you the fans pick the
fans are saying right now the number one
is Derwin James that's right he's still
available for you number two the fans
pick will Hernandez the guard out of
Texas El Paso so they're both available
in your ma I thought about giving both
of them to them I certainly did but
instead but let me just say this okay
first of all they got got Justin Brits
their Center they drafted the Ethan pop
pot chicken last year right okay so he's
on their roster okay but I'm not putting
too much
into DJ fluke or ECMO no tell me a lot i
hear you it's not the prettiest group in
the world but at some point they got to
start making some of these assets work i
mean do we know jeepers is still there
george Fant they're starting left tackle
is still there yes I'm not gonna let you
sit here after talking about George fat
being a basketball player yeah then make
it an argument like he's therefore dead
well okay but you but he was still a
starting left tackle nor was he I know
he wasn't great but when he got hurt he
was getting better we were we were
saying that too yes we made fun of them
so my bottom line is I didn't go
offensive line I went in with Derwin
James Turin James I mean they need a new
camp chancellor do we even know if cam
chancer can play football this year yet
is that Ben says right that would worry
me that's kind of a fall there tutor and
James fall on the 18th as a seeming like
a big fly it does it does for me i doand
James yes it sounds like him on the
podcast on Wednesday very real
possibility he goes in the top 12
because I've heard everything from 7 to
the Bucs yeah even the 6 to the Colts to
around this range 8 into the early 20s
yeah so who'll be a guy to watch on Jeff
yeah I mean even the Redskins who we
talking about I had them take maker like
that would certainly be in their
preferences and I'm sure there's teams
the NFL deciding between those two guys
no doubt about it I really like Durham
and James I love the attitude in which
he plays he's like a day on Buchanan to
me more like that way he said in the box
type safety you don't want him in space
or covering people if there's one
weakness to his football game is short
area quickness like I don't know if he's
necessarily gonna be great at that but
as far as running straight ahead and
playing with attitude and physicality
Mandarin when James is like he's a
better version of kam chancellor when he
was coming out Wow
alright so America's former team Dallas
Cowboys taking it at 19 you go in Calvin
Ridley here nope oh you go in DJ more
here yes I am alright I knew they'd have
to go wide receiver I mean do they or
could they have gotten linebacker that
was it so I became between or who were
you deciding him Andrew Sean Evans it
was one of the two because they didn't
lose Anthony Hitchens and are you really
gonna gamble the farm on Sean Lee and
you know why and one legged Willie
kid : hi J Lanson I heard about them I
didn't say that's hilarious
I look at the Cowboys and I believe that
Shawn Lee gets hurt every other year so
I think that Shawn Lee will get hurt
probably this year I don't want that to
happen I like Shawn Lee so you went
between Evans and DJ more your top live
receiver yeah and you picked more
because you looked at their wide
receiver record went wow this is bad I
exactly right I just said I mean really
I mean can we do this you can't go out
there with that group and then their
offensive system it's not the most
creative in the world anyways they like
to use just simple mechanics and
basically going is that why you like
more than more more than Riddley because
more can create on the zone and deadly
yeah definitely yes I mean yes that's
exactly I mean more more is the kind of
guy that teams when they play the Dallas
Cowboy you're gonna go damn are we
really gonna put the extra guy in the
box and leave him one-on-one with more
to him I don't know we can do that it's
it's now as an Eagles fan
I'm realizing that the Giants might have
say Kwan and Odell and if the Cowboys
have more and you spoke in this highly
of him seek its matchup nightmare oh
yeah what more is more can be spent with
tax ability to run yeah right and more
can do like Percy Harvin stuff to where
he lines up in the backfield and placed
tailback in college like yeah he is he's
one of my favorite players in the draft
you know that I've said that from the
start he is certainly one of the he's
the best receiver in the draft of the
ball in his hand and even though he's
only like six foot maybe he's 6 1 I
don't even have the measurables in front
of me either way he's a phenomenal 50/50
ball catcher scary it's so to me it just
made too much sense we are now at pick
20 Matt Patricia and the Detroit Lions
with Bob Quinn as their GN yeah depth in
the D line linebacker I think their old
line is better than some people think
they've needed a running back now for
years but I don't know if there's a guy
worthy of this pick and they need to
replace Eric Ebron so where are you
going right now with Detroit they were
they were one of the more intriguing
teams here a lot of possible possible
your tell the linebackers they signed in
free agency so where you going deal I
well I mean it came down a cornerback
running back tight in and D tackle you
hit on him I think you're exactly
this this is basically what it came down
to me the fans are picking Durham pain
out of Alabama oh I thought about that
certainly that was certainly went
through my head but let me look there
there's a little more size and big
people on this defensive line then I
think everybody realizes they'd signed
to Sylvester Williams they got Hakeem
Spence they got a Shaun Robinson and
they got a lot of guys that are six two
and six three that are 295 300 pounds
the Anthony's Edel's Harry Hyder will
come back exactly right so I looked at
that and just said man I don't know if I
see that here now then my on my mind
didn't go bad would they go Sony Michele
here maybe something like that get a
running back but this is Bob Quinn and
New England they're not - yeah right
they're not doing that so then I went
tight-end and I thought man Titan could
be a possibility this is New England
they believe in that but they just
signed Luke Wilson right yeah toy Lolo's
there but the big thing it came down to
me is who's the new head coach Patricia
and the man needs corners exactly she go
Jair Alexander's a great pick thank you
thank you I just yeah they're a team and
he could be a punt kick return option
exactly and how many times he like we're
always talking about man like the they
need another playmaker in the back end
it's just Darius slay we talked I
understand that there's other good
players but they need a true difference
maker Matt Patricia loves the play
man-to-man now he has this guy he can
put on an island seriously I'm not
trusting to Sean shed - they sign or
Nevin Lawson I think if you have Darius
layin Jags Alexander and Glover Quinn
took that step up this year yeah you saw
fire you suddenly have three or four
really good defensive backs and you're
playing Aaron Rodgers and you're playing
Kirk Cousins - you're playing mark
exactly alright so that is 11 through 20
yeah so you guys have heard the top 10
already if not hit or rewind 11v Nevaeh
- the Dolphins the Broncos having traded
with the bills at 12 take Denzel Ward
good value there Washington gets Minka
Fitzpatrick at 13
the Packers get Mike Hughes at 14 the
Cardinals shocked the world and go Lamar
Jackson
the Ravens get their new Terrell Suggs
and Harold Landry that
Sam darn 'old at 17 if it happens you're
a genius Alex at 18 get Derwin James
their new Chancellor Cowboys go DJ more
as their new Dez Bryant and the Lions go
joy year Alexander at 20 so who are the
big guys that you haven't taken yet
trying to think well there's a lot here
I mean really none of the other
offensive linemen have gone there's no
Calvin Ridley right
there's no Doron Payne Harvard Sean
Evans we talked about it linebacker you
know he's still there didn't Hayden
Hearst say the number one fan picked for
the Bengals at 21 is Rashad Evans right
and because I feel like the Bengals of
needed linebackers now for the last five
years
feeling every draft it's like they could
use a linebacker but yeah with Vaughn
tez seemingly who knows right suspended
for four games right they did sign
Preston Brown right as a linebacker this
offseason I think you need for Courtney
Glen with the bills yes so they got the
tackle and at some point again I just
look at it and go damn like you know I
thought about offensive line but you
know at somebody you could just gotta
let the guys you drafted like these guys
like you know the chip what's his name
from Oregon I'm blanking Fisher right
Jake Fisher Jake Fisher said Racal bleh
he write like they're gonna they got a
play they can't abandon ship on first
and second-round picks three years after
so to me I just can't imagine them going
old line again here to me the biggest
thing they have an issue is they need
big people and that's where neuron pain
comes in
they have no more dome atop echo know
they were they to injure Billings and
Geno Atkins right now they're starting
tackles it's not big enough they did
sign Chris Baker right but he's not that
big it's like you want him to be like a
rotational guys you don't want him being
your stress and reason he's been on the
Redskins in the body you like pain I
like pain a lot I mean so they're
missing their dome atop Petco right this
is the 30th ranked run defense in
football last year I mean everybody ran
the ball down the throat of the banjos
pain is like you know Geno Atkins
getting up there in age and pain is like
a guy who he can he's strong enough to
be that shade nose tackle to where you
go just take on
does he compare to a Shaun Robinson he's
uh I think he's a better player than a
genre coming out yeah I was really
impressed you know
remember who my pro player comparison
was for Doron Payne
no come on short oh I really thought
he's got a big time now Bill's Panthers
yeah yeah the bills got star little
Layla from the Panthers book yes so the
Durham pain right there all right so is
this the Broncos pick at 22 the Broncos
so you're giving 22 and 12 I don't know
I thought about being cute and being
like oh I'll give them pick 12 and next
year's second and third and I was like
whatever I'm just gonna give them I'm
not Johnny [ __ ] drafted the Broncos
trade down from five they get Denzel
Ward at 12 and where do they go at 22
yeah
few things I looked at I mean I looked
at the receiver a little bit you know I
mean Demaryius getting up there and
Emmanuel they're built in you know eight
years in the NFL but I think at the end
of the day I had to go home line to me
there's still question marks on that old
line I know they got Garrett Bowles at
left tackle you got guys like Ronald
Leary was a good player but he went out
of the lineup yeah heard a lot didn't
play as great last year you know you got
Menelik Watson at right tackle who has
been hurt in an out of line of his whole
career so if I'm a John Elway I just
can't sit there and go oh yeah I'm
content with this offensive line they're
gonna be fine I'm going with my big man
will Hernandez is it will yes yes but
UTEP you like him yes oh geez though
he's good I mean I won't be shocked if
he went somewhere between 10 and 20
before this he is especially because we
talked about how hard it is to find good
offensive linemen yes
that when they come around I can
understand if they're over drafted yeah
I totally can add it to the fact like
you made it the great point before it
interior defensive linemen have become
so popular and offensive linemen are so
hard to find coming out of college right
now especially think about that division
yeah facing Khalil Mac von Miller and
the Bosa and Ingram bad boys right you
need offensive linemen for whatever
quarterbacks going back there and you
know what so if what's a better duo the
Browns leaving and this is kind of
self-explanatory but Josh Allen and
Bradley Chubb or the Broncos trading
down and getting Denzel
yes that's a pretty good poll it's a
really good poll because Hernandez is
really impressive and you were saying
too that if the Broncos didn't make the
trade with the bills you could see them
just staying pat and taking quit Nelson
at five I do yes it's another good
guarded journey to is pretty good right
it is and this guy is I mean again for
his size this guy a 6-4 okay
and he's 346 pounds I didn't realize he
was that big until I started watching
and ad just 340 48 yeah and he carries
really carries it well he doesn't have
the greatest legs that I always like
he's old hair top-heavy but man the
filmic speech for it's just for my brain
yeah how much better is Quintin Nelson
than will her name is it's not it's not
what do we got it as you know it's 15
picks it's not 15 picks better Wow no
it's it's I think after I got done I
said I mean Quintin Nelson's definitely
the best guard in the draft but this guy
wasn't that far number two he's
definitely my number two he's a really
impressive ople player and more athletic
than his combine drills showed too and
you get to see him against big-time
competition now I could talk about will
Hernandez come on the Broncos at 22 for
a long time but I don't tell you yeah
the Patriots are on the call the
Patriots the fans are picking Colton
Miller tackle from UCLA yeah who's Chris
Sims Pickett well that it certainly fits
and I thought about that yes Sean Evans
stole the board's bruh Sean Evans is on
the board who you owe now the Patriots
so they have stole just a ton of
linebackers so I just could I just when
I sat there and watch him you pulling up
the roster yeah I just thought man I
don't know if I could see them quite
doing this and this is another thing I
came back to left Co and again maybe I'm
wrong but I just think if I'm running
the Patriots and this is the style of
play we play who's there other corner
right mm-hmm
their corners right now or Jason
McCourty and Stephon Gilmore and then
Eric Roe and Jonathan Jones so how much
corners were left
you're not going Josh Jackson I know
that no I'm going with one of my other
favorites Carlton Davis from Auburn and
you think he'd fit that system I do
I mean Carleton Davis is one of the
least talked about he's a definite first
rounder for me I think he's gonna be the
name that's gonna shock a lot of people
when it comes up because you're gonna be
like yes good pick everyone else to be
like yeah what we took the best tall
corner in the draft to ran for five and
covered every receiver in the SEC
man-to-man and shut them down oh how
dare we yeah he's one of these guys for
whatever reason flying under the radar
because there are some sexy names I
guess in at that position but man the
film speaks for itself you talk about in
your face man to man
type corner unbelievably long arms and
for a tall guy to his short area
quickness ability to change direction
whatever way you want to phrase it is
top notch six one two oh six ran for
five three
he plays faster than four or five three
on film to me he's better than already
Burns was coming out he is a really
really good football player like I will
not be shocked in five years of people
go Carlton Davis is the best corner in
this draft or maybe the best corner in
football he is that kind of player and I
will not be shot I love it alright so
number 24 so Calvin Ridley still out
there just Jackson still out there
Rashad Evans is still out there number
of other big names were Carolina yeah at
24 where are you going
yeah I mean I thought about a line or
corner those are the two things I
thought about now I'm not sure if
there's quite a corner on there that
really fits it at this point in the
draft right now Oh line you know I know
they lost
Andrew nor well they have people on
their own line I don't think they're
decimated there I don't look at them and
go all if they don't get a no line of
the first around they're screwed to me I
look at Morgan go damn if they don't get
somebody else or for my men to throw the
football to they're screwed and that's
where I'm going with Calvin Ridley
that's a pretty good pick for them it is
too solid wide receiver he's not my
second favorite receiver or my third but
that's exactly why I'm doing it he's not
your second or third I don't think he is
know I think I had more in DJ shark
ahead of him Wow
but to me again almost like the Denzel
Ward to Denver here I got to take a guy
that I know can come in and play and be
smart and just be dependable
right now and Ridley is the most
polished NFL ready
his necessarily explosiveness and what
he does with the ball in his hand does
not excite me as much as some of these
other receivers in the draft but he's
going to be able to do it all they can't
do a big receiver like cam Sutton we've
already Kelvin but they already have
Devin Funchess so if they do the big
receiver again think I don't even know
what to say
Curtis Samuels okay hope with gentlemen
gone it's changed I would hope so -
Curtis Salmons you can't depend on that
quite yet to be your number two it was
too easy for him to get hurt so it did
seem like that so to me yes that's the
play here Calvin Ridley I think they I
think Cam Newton would appreciate that
25 20 times see Titans the first thing
that comes to my mind is I need big
people in the trenches yeah that's what
came to my mind and I think that's part
of where my thinking is here too I don't
think they can go off into line I don't
see that hammer things lines good it's
great right I mean I couldn't get over
how many people had the mock taking off
in Salinas I'm seeing one right now I
mean they took two tackles in the first
round two years in a row I mean they
have what Josh Klein is one guard do
they just gave a ton of money to they
who's their Center Ben Jones from the
Houston Texans so I'm gonna predict that
you you've already given the whole
country who's that coach of Raible right
so Rashad Evans that went into my mind
but there's an I thought you were gonna
pick Tevan Brian a Florida I thought
about him too the defensive tackle
they're a little bit better on the
interior D line than you know when we
like you and I like Benny Logan's
they're right you get Darrell Casey got
to Quan Jones you got Austin Johnson
right so to me that's what kind of
played into that and I was like yeah
okay I'm not sure if that's the way they
go come on who's Mike Vrabel in this
draft it's not gonna be yeah that's who
I'm going with
but you don't even why did you pick him
there you're the GM I I got a big Layton
van Irish fans I I'm not necessarily
like yeah I mean I'm not like in love
with the guy I get that but I think this
is where I came into my rationale he can
do a lot of different things right away
at the linebacker position this is a new
scheme they've lost Avery Williamson yes
the kid has potential there's no like
denying
because of the size and the athleticism
it's very apparent do I wish he played
more physically certainly but I think
for a guy where I think ultimately he's
going to be on the outside is it because
you watch the Patriots in their past
offense destroy the Titans linebackers
that you thought we need to get a
linebacker that can cover they
definitely need that yes that's truly a
positional need right and I also go into
Iraq pose getting up there Derek Morgan
or getting up there and we know those
names but they're not nearly as good as
we think they are right so that to me is
where he comes into play and I just felt
like you know I've been tough like I was
tough on this type of guy with JJ Watt
last year TJ watt where I was like I
wish I had a little bit more but I think
what sometimes I underestimate is just
their their value to the NFL game is
actually more than in college and I
think that's where a guy like this
because he can play outside linebacker
if they needed to play three-four inside
linebacker he can do that but at the end
of the day I think Vrabel is gonna have
a guy that can do a lot of different
things on his front seven and he's gonna
look at him and go kind of reminds me of
me when I was coming out yeah I play
into that Falcons at 26 the Internet is
saying Isaiah win the guard out of
Georgia yeah second pick is Wake Forest
safety Jesse Bates and then Billy price
Center from Ohio safe I like all of
those but going I'm going with Haven
Brian your guy had a four in Florida yes
I am put him next to a lost down Terry
Poe forgot to remember that he can PI D
tackle he could play D end he could be
basically the Michael Bennett of this
defense to a degree he's a bigger man
than Michael Bennett but man is he
unbelievably disruptive and athletic so
you want the gray t Jarrett Taven Brian
combination I think so I think that's
what CFL video of Grady Jerry right
man's over 300 pounds and has a six-pack
he's he is I mean some guys together yes
that's pretty gnarly and then we get
back to why interior offensive line or
so import Dan Quinn I just think he's in
the one his defense and his front seven
to be a little different I think that I
mean I mean a little
more of a difference maker yeah and you
know their offensive line what was
what's the desperate need there I mean I
know it's not perfect but damn I mean
it's pretty good they've run the ball
good they pass protect good I don't I
don't sit there and go those were able
to run on them too yes the Eagles
overpowered them I mean that game went
exactly remember how we said it they can
make it ugly and just overpower this and
they did that so 27 the Saints 27 the
Saints what are you giving Sean Payton
Powell
that means the Saints are one of the one
from the fans was Dallas go dirt
O'Connor yeah yeah
South to go to state the tight end yeah
I certainly could see that I mean the
Saints the Eagles and the Jags arts
truly can make like what I would call
[ __ ] you picks like so good and we can
just pick the best player available or
the one that excites us the most every
maybe
I think the Saints the thing that makes
sense to me is Hayden Hearst the tight
end from South Carolina gotcha
I think he's better than the kid from
South Dakota first always a better
blocker that's what I could tell you for
sure I really was impressed with Hayden
her son Phil
Hayden hearses some little athlete first
of all he brings it blocking left go I
mean he will try to knock people's heads
off I really like that about him I think
it fits what their offense wants to do
and if it's Sean Payton exactly and he's
really good in the past game I mean
really good like a good route runner
because you know what the Saints they
give him the Travis Kelce stuff I know
and really he fits in perfect I sigh you
know listen the Saints maybe pass rusher
I don't think there's a pass rusher on
the board right here that's worth taking
at this spot I think Hayden Hearst is
the pick they don't need two offensive
linemen in my opinion yeah unless you're
gonna reach for like a Lorenzo Carter or
rasheem green I thought about it but
their defensive line in order to go
right and I don't see them that way like
Lorenzo Carter is a better player but
he's not like a top-tier pass rusher
he's gonna be a great strong right good
defense anything Hurst could end up
being a little speck I think Hersh can
be special yes next up is the Pittsburgh
Steelers at the 28 steel but this is I
mean this wrote itself
I mean who got hurt what linebackers on
the board who got hurt for that oh I
can't believe that your linebacker still
is still there Rashad Evans right and it
just I was like damn okay
it's not like I intended this to happen
but I just as like oh this makes too
much sense Rashad Evans is on the board
and this was their biggest issue and I'm
going back yeah the Panthers took Rashad
Evans yeah Thomas Davis and Kuechly
would that fit well yeah it would but
are they ever gonna let the kid they
drafted in the first round out of a team
Shaquille shaquita Shaq Shaq Mason not
Mason Thompson sacked off yes
Shaq Masons with the Patriots but
Steelers and Rashad Evans would be just
a match made in heaven
match made in heaven I mean this is what
they need they need that athletic middle
linebacker Evans has come from a 3-4
defense he'll be used to a lot of the
stuff they do here and yeah I mean they
were there are their middle linebacker
play was the reason they lost to the
Jaguars in that AFC Championship or a
divisional playoff game and it was an
issue from once right Ryan shazier got
hurt then on they need a
difference-maker on that part of their
defense Jaguars at 29 Jaguars at 29 are
in the like I told you the upper jaw up
your butt Jobu pic here cuz what do they
need tell me I mean back you know I
thought maybe they could go receiver but
I looked at their receiving core and I
said damn I mean they got a lot of good
and Tom Coughlin is a receiver coach and
he's probably like I'm not gonna waste a
first-round pick on a receiver I
complain gave them a wide receiver too
but right now they have marquise Lee
Donte Moncrief Rashad Greene jaelen
strong DD Westbrook keel and Cole Shane
Wynn I mean how many they need a lot of
Rights
I mean Dede we know how much they I
would bet my money on Leigh Cole and
Dede yes right those would be the three
I'd better right I mean Dede they they
Dede didn't play the whole year and it
came to week 12 and they're like you up
you're starting you're in the game so I
was Jacksonville I'd probably go for
offensive line depth I thought about
that I did just because I don't know how
their offensive line made it work last
year and I know there's some good
interior lineman but who did you go well
there is some good interior I mean but
why what what their offensive line was
good last year I know I'm just saying
getting Dan they signed Andrew Norwell
right I know I know I'm just saying I'm
just talking a tality I just say when in
doubt I like adding offensive linemen
all the time to me the biggest thing
again for a team that is the most well
built team in the sport right now this
is the best roster in the game don't get
it confused there number one I I'll only
looked at only so they need a nickel
corner and I'm going with Dante Jackson
from Iowa I mean now Iowa LSU Dante
Jackson from LSU and he's a weapon he's
a weapon now listen they're right
because they just lost what's his name
Colvin Aaron call to the Texans yes and
I don't see that guy in their roster
right now and this is a team that's
ready right now so to me I just look at
that and you go you need that guy who
could be likes free safety and /u
players seemingly always panel right and
the only issue you have with this guy
he's 510 178 ok live in the nickel he's
gonna live and he's them he's made for a
nickel yeah then 178 is even light for a
nickel I get that but man Denzel warden
them aren't that much bigger I mean
that's not that much of a difference man
and man I just watched the guy play the
whole season in the SEC and there's just
NFL running back some receivers all over
the blade and he just takes him to the
ground like they're nothing so that to
me I just if I'm the Jacksonville
Jaguars I'm trying to win the Superbowl
that's what I'm doing Minnesota Vikings
at 30 Minnesota I'm going d-line I know
they could sink people they can
certainly use depth on their D line but
but you do I just think they have a
bigger need there I think that our
interior offensive line you know the
bergstrom guys not playing I think they
go guard here that would be the play for
me which you just gave 90 hundred
million trillion dollars to so you got
to protect her cousins I'm going with my
man Daniels from Iowa I'm blanking on
his first name right now I have too many
names in my head I just he's he's Iowa
Center that's what he is to me here it
is but this is James James excuse me so
James James is the best center in the
draft I don't think he'll play Center
just because they have a center but I
would say James is the best guard in the
draft to for me I don't really quit
Nelson I mean other than him and bully
her name he's the next guard that was
the third yes he's the third best but
yes I look at him and just go what
whether they want to play him at center
and put elf line at guard or they want
to just make this guy the guard but I
just looked at Rick Spielman what
they've collected at the guard position
it's usually somebody along this type of
frame of body that's not overly huge
bulking keppa gaya can move at some
athleticism it's the cookie cutter man I
think he does he's 6-3 he's 295 he's got
incredible get off incredible punch I
mean quick hands he's really a
tremendous Center so that's where I was
like I don't know maybe I just go with a
true guard here but I just don't think
you can go wrong with having this guy
starting as here figure it out I mean
he's gonna be fine either way I just go
maybe they should just make him the
center and make alpha in the guard but
al finds a good center - all right let
me recap 21 through 30 before we finish
the last two picks 21 was the Bengals
you had him taking Doron Payne adding a
big man in the middle the Broncos are
able to get will Hernandez with the
second of two first-round picks they get
for the bills the Patriots
Carlton what's his Davis out of Auburn
in the corner it's for the replacing of
Malcom Butler the Panthers then come
back with Calvin Ridley at 24
the Titans get Mike Vrabel jr. in Layton
Vander Esch then we go to the Falcons
and they're taking Bryan from Florida
the defensive tackle as in their new
Michael Bennett the Saints go hayden
hearst the tight end out of South
Carolina
the Steelers come back and get Rashad
Evans who's made to where the from the
black and yellow black and yellow the
Jaguars are gonna go Dante Jackson to
get their slot corner to make their
Super Bowl run the Vikings then go mr.
Daniels
out of Iowa to figure out their
offensive line shift him from Center to
guard and now the Patriots at 31 where
are they going we said his name already
Colton Miller the sanstead of taking
about 23 they're able to wait and get
him at 39 III mean I certainly could see
that happening and I don't know if he's
gonna last that long I don't know if
we're gonna we're gonna there's gonna be
a run on tackle there there certainly
could be I mean yes there's some teams
in front of them that could but I also
look
a lot of those teams that were in front
of them that couldn't just go damn I
mean they have other needs where I just
thought it was risky like they don't
have to worry about too many teams
between their pick at 23 and to where
they're that there's not a whole lot of
tackling systems right
Colton Miller could Dantes karne Kia
make him one of the next great Patriots
attack I do think he could be I mean
listen I when I you know you're looking
on nfl.com like Lanzer line he even
compared him because who is he broke
Nate's older I get that he's a lot like
Nate Salter coming out he really is he's
6 9 he's 310 pounds he's got incredibly
long arms so he fits all the measurables
that the Patriots believe for in tackle
right they don't necessarily have to get
him out there in year one they have
tackles ready right now so it's not like
a desperate thing but I think at the end
of the day yeah it's an important
position and I think that he could be
left tackle or right tackle
year one whatever away he can get on the
field eventually he's going to be your
left tackle he's a little stiff at times
I wish he could be a little lower off
the ball right but either way pass
protection he's very athletic in those
arms another great 2 player draft for a
team Patriots yeah those two yeah and
now the Super Bowl champion Philadelphia
Eagles select who are you giving them
what did you I mean I told you already
right so you can't act too surprised you
don't remember good alright so what did
you want to do what do you think you're
you'll want to do I am someone that
wants a linebacker just because I don't
trust Jordan Hicks I think when in doubt
we can always go offensive line and add
some interior oh line depth there's what
you could that the value is there for
some guys and there are look there's
gonna be a lot of good interior
offensive line and then I could also
understand the going and getting a Sony
Michele at running back yeah I get that
too I know you're going with I'm going
with DJ charkh receiver from LSU yes I
mean the running back thing I thought
about but damn I mean you still got
Wendell Smallwood Cory Clement JJ I mean
Cory Clements the reason why I don't
need them to exactly back because I
believe he's gonna take
huge stuff that wasn't me that sold me
to because I thought about Sony Michelle
year to me other than Berkeley Sony
Michelle's the only other boy Clemente
in the Super Bowl yes he was incredible
right and so you're going wide reciever
but then Mike Wallace is speedy already
yeah but Mike Wallace is what you're
nine are we talking about here I mean
trust me he is year 10 he ain't running
like DJ shark is right now so you see
charkas just a weapon that they don't
have in their office I exactly right I
think DJ like again you guys are a team
that can kind of just draft anything I
don't think there's a linebacker there
that's worthy of that 32 pick with the
other guys off the bra the board already
so when I looked at it yeah the
offensive line thing certainly came into
play but you still got a good amount of
well that's alive listen I have faith in
Holly pull the avati of I time yeah and
I just looked at your receivers and you
don't really have that guy I mean Mike
Wallace just man he wasn't good last
year in Baltimore it's hard for me to
just go oh okay he'll be the guy I yeah
I mean I just go man you got Carson once
would you know our big man Alshon
Jeffery and Aguilar are working the slaw
and then you got DJ shark that people
are gonna have to worry about going holy
cow
DJ shark is one of these guys in the
draft that I don't understand why there
hasn't been more busts about really good
route runner six three a little over 200
pounds
oh yeah and ran the fastest time in the
combine and I just don't understand
yeah and it's also I was just gonna say
also the thing that drives me crazy is I
feel like if his stats were better
people would put him up there and I want
to go we'll have you watched the film
cuz if he had a quarterback he'd have an
extra 400 yards easily cuz all those
plays that should have been 70 yard
touchdowns ended up being 40 yard
completions cuz he had a stop or come
back or the quarterback didn't even
throw it or he threw it so bad he
couldn't even make something happen with
it
so I look at it and just go so if he was
a guy that had like 1200 yards receiving
I feel like everybody bid he's a top 20
pick look at his measurable as his size
he's got it all good route runner just
to the ball well I mean that would be
awesome if you guys got him there don't
sleep on Matt Collins I know he is he
did really well at you me yeah how does
it feel getting your mock draft out
there it feels good it feels I'm just
glad I'm done was watching film and crap
holy crap it was stressing me out
on Wednesday the stick to football
podcast and these Sims and left go
podcast will be coming together for AGM
roundtable Sims will be my pro player
personnel Matt Miller will be my head of
college scouting and Connor Rodgers will
be my director of regional scouting and
you're gonna make the pick I'm gonna be
the GM and we're gonna run through
probably the top five just because I
think that's when it's gonna get crazy
right I want to hear you guys arguing
about the quarterbacks and all that
stuff okay it's gonna be good tomorrow
we have which people Josh Rosen Rosen
won Bradley Chubb and then we're gonna
see who else but that's gonna be just
some player interviews tomorrow and then
also we're expected to have Derwin James
with us on Wednesday so yeah big week
for the podcast and then Thursday live
draft be sure to check it out on the
bleacher report Facebook page and you
can stream it in the BR app so make sure
you watch that we're doing every pic
we're not slowing down we're only giving
you the goods the good Sims peace out
homies forfend rec good evening everyone
and for the lef koe man that was Chris
Simmons as mock draft I hope you enjoyed
it we'll be back all this week join us
see you soon